yeah that [__] doesn't happen to me ever
getting flirted with yeah but it did it
just reminds me of it because I want to
tell you about this anyways the like
Omega dinner that I went to yeah yeah
and there was this one moment where
we're standing it was just a big dinner
what there's a just a mega dinner I want
to tell you about the mega dinner that I
went to it just hang out with some
English people Austin it was smack up
man that's my God
no I said Maga
apparently you can come out and tell us
how much you hate the vaccine
got a table this Mega dinner passed me
that hat real fast
uh no
Omega yeah the watch company yeah they
uh they saw that I wore one on the red
carpet of the Golden Globes so they
didn't want to pick that name up real
quick they what you just want to pick
that name up
um I was I was there too
yeah exactly there you go
um oh name drop yeah yeah
damn dude well you can't really name
drop an event can you
I mean Golden Globes yeah yeah I'll even
pick that up sorry don't do it
sorry solid gold sorry about that big
old Globes dude
Omega Omega glow Omega Globe my my my so
they reach out to
uh rpr and they were like okay we
they're doing a pre-oscars dinner and
they want you to go
and uh so I went the CEO was there so
it's like the CEO of the
um us Swatch division right six it's
probably like 75 people there like the
guy that played Versace in that show
what's his name
great actor not Adam Driver anyways it
was like I just felt like really out of
place because
we don't go to [__] like that very often
yeah and they sat me beside the CEO and
he was like because I'm not like I'm not
really a watch guy but I like watches
sure but I've not like I've never like
collected them you know you were sitting
next to Ricky Martin
yeah him yeah
um
dude it was like a cool it was like a
cool group of people to be there it was
just like felt like crazy and then they
sat me beside the [__] guy and he was
like really nice guy and we're talking
about he's a cyclist so we're talking
about cycling stuff like that where like
you know geeking out yeah geeking out a
little bit like I'm like okay this is
going well and then he's like how did he
find out you're a cyclist
I think uh I mean I probably said
something I don't know Mike
what I just said bike
he's like so how are you cycling
thoughts
do you like bicycle yeah
so what do you like to do Cody I wired
bicycles I like I like to ride bicycles
my bicycles really fast I like I got a
new bicycle a brand new bike
that's basically how it started and then
he he he broke character and he's like
oh I like bicycle too he's like I like
bicycles too how fast you go yeah
and he he like leans over me like it's
going well and then he was like so how
many watches do you own
and I was like uh
zero and then I was like ah actually no
one tried to recover because I actually
do have a watch that my parents got me
when I graduated college let's just
graduated high school it's a Timex yeah
it's a little like plastic Swatch yeah
yeah
and uh anyways I felt really embarrassed
you're like because he was like oh
okay
look at his head he's like why are you
at this dinner yeah yeah like I don't
know I have no idea we were standing
like before the dinner and one of like
the cocktail like waitresses came up
with like a thing of food and like
smiled like way too hard at me oh and
she was offering me the thing and I was
like thanks and Kelsey was like I think
she was flirting with you and I was like
I thought that too and I just don't
didn't want to be a dick yeah never
happens yeah ever
yeah
I think FedEx ladies only time I've been
hit on outside of my relationship
yeah
yeah sure let me grab one of those
little hors d'oeuvres yeah thank you so
much yeah you know
whoa what do we got going on here yeah
make a little little Tuna Taco sure let
me get one of those tuna tacos yes
let me just pick it up with this finger
no yeah when the FedEx lady hit on me I
went back down to the decade Helena was
there and
I said I think the FedEx lady was
flirting with me
she's like what
I said yeah she was like asking me my
age
and she's like that's really she's like
that's really funny like
you know typically it's the other way
around
what you hit on the FedEx no no
yeah
no no it's like when when uh
when a FedEx was like the you know UPS
driver shows up in the shorts and the
wife is like uh yeah yeah all right the
delivery man yeah like in uh Legally
Blonde yeah yeah yeah but this time you
know what I'm talking about good job
Cody yeah yeah I I nailed a reference
yeah
who is also in White Lotus
wow ladies and gentlemen
we can up we can we can update the board
days since reference
[Laughter]
well you know what's cool about Jennifer
or Jennifer Coolidge too is that is that
we saw her at the Golden Globes yeah
all right drop my bagel pure gold name
drop
18 karat name drop right there yeah you
have a watch
no
see that's what I did that's what I did
when the guy asked me
what is that yeah I have a Rolex
yeah that would have probably been the
worst answer
no I I have a Rolex of a Kermit actually
it was gifted to me by a fan
but do you like watches I do I just
don't want to pay for them yeah just ask
them for him he sure just said can I
have one
well okay so then we were talking to I
was talking to some other guy who I
guess was like uh I don't know he works
in like branding or something like that
sorry I gotta just say real quick it
would have been hilarious if you're like
does he have any watches you're like
crazy thing dude I actually have an
Omega Submariner but it's fake
I went to China I got a [__] dude and
yeah dude I bought 10 of them and I sold
them here as real ones
I cash the [__] out you also start doing
that
dude that would be that's some like gen
Z yeah like low-key I have all your
watches but they're fake
guys like what the [__] what the [__]
this guy's a genius hire him anyway
you're talking to this so we're talking
to this guy he's he's an agent he works
in branding and he said he has some
clients that work with Omega and they
were in Switzerland that's where that
was another thing he's telling me kind
of interesting like all the luxury watch
brands are within their headquarters are
all within a mile of each other in this
one town in Switzerland for some reason
they all ended up there yeah he was
there for an event and like the sea the
global CEO I forget what his name is
um of Swatch group was there at this
event and he asked like they were like
drinking together and he asked him was
like do you have do you have a watch yet
and the guy was like oh no I don't and
he just picked up like a Speed Max for
speed master or whatever it's called
from the like middle of the table and
just gave it to him
isn't that crazy
I mean it's a lot of power yeah
here you go I think it's like an 8 000
watch or something it's pretty sick
that's nuts
Omega
I like watches I actually do
I used to wear a fake Breitling in
college nice no one knew it was fake
like I knew no one knew what a Breitling
was
and so it was like a little treat for me
yeah I got to pretend I had a Breitling
and no one was you know any wise to it
like yeah
paid 150 bucks for it nice yeah stopped
working after like six months oh yeah I
have a tog healer or tag here yeah no
you got it okay you had to talk on that
is that what it is something like that
and they're nice right yeah yeah they're
nice watches the one I have has a little
Duke D in it
just I thought you was a little Duke in
there yeah a little dookie yeah yeah we
were partying hard and we were swimming
in the lake I don't know I got some Duke
in there
other than that it's a clean watch
no but it's a nice memory you know of
yeah did you buy it from the school
no that's what my parents got me when I
graduated oh that's that's cute yeah put
a little D in there knowing your dad
he's like yeah I actually looked up how
to open it up and I opened I put a
custom watch face in there yeah and it's
all carbon fiber now yeah super light
actually I put a Bluetooth chip in there
it normally doesn't come with that now I
basically invented the air tag before
the air tag I didn't feel like selling
it or whatever so it's there um and I
actually wrote the software for air tag
20 years in advance of it coming out so
um yeah there's gonna be something in
the future it's called air tag when it
comes out this watch will be synced to
your phone no problem just put it to the
side of your phone because they have to
invent that too yeah I actually like
wrote the patents and I gave it to them
because I don't feel like dealing with
it but yeah that's all you yeah
yeah he did say those exact words and
you're like thanks Dan I just wanted a
fire truck yeah
I want a white bike